Apple's iPhone 11 series is now
available to order and since Apple
decided to call their flagship model Pro
we decided to compare it to the best
Android smartphone ever made Samsung's
Galaxy Note 10 to the nine phones you
should buy this video is for you first
off the iPhone 11 pro max starts at the
same exact price as the note 10 plus
however you're getting more value right
off the bat with the note since it comes
with 256 gigabytes of storage compared
to only 64 gigabytes on the iPhone which
is honestly quite embarrassing and the
galaxy comes with a micro SD card slot
supporting up to an extra one terabyte
of storage so the notes n+ is easily the
value king for storage not only that but
the note also comes with 12 gigabytes of
RAM compared to either four or six on
the 11pro
but iPhones are known for utilizing the
RAM better than Android phones so we'll
have to see if it's actually enough
design-wise the note has a larger
display with ultra thin bezels on the
front and a very small cutout for the
selfie camera so it looks much better
compared to the iPhone which has thicker
bezels all around and the same old
notches before the iPhone needs to hold
a bunch of sensors for face ID and other
features like that so it'll be
interesting to see how Apple deals with
the knotch next year face ID is already
pretty great on the iPhone 10s
especially while using iOS 13 beta so
it's very exciting that face ID will be
getting faster work at greater angles
and from further away they know what 10
plus does have facial recognition but is
pretty easily fooled
so most people will be using the
ultrasonic fingerprint scanner instead
which is pretty great but it's much
slower than optical scanners on other
phones like the 1 plus 7 Pro on the back
the iPhone has a new square camera bump
that you'll either absolutely hate or
love and I personally think it looks
much better than all the pre-release
renders however the note 10 pluses
vertical camera layout is very clean and
almost everyone will love it one thing
that'll be very interesting to test out
is the new matte glass finish on the
back of the 11pro so we'll have to see
which phone feels more premium in the
hand the cameras themselves are
outstanding on the note 10 plus and my
opinion is the best camera on any
smartphone out there so I have to see if
the
improvements to the iPhone 11 pros
cameras will bring it back to the top
the iPhone 10s already records the best
video quality you can get on a
smartphone so I'm glad Apple is further
pushing their lead in this area with the
iPhone 11 Pro we'll be doing an in-depth
photo night mode and video quality
comparison when we get our hands on the
phones so make sure to subscribe right
now so you don't miss out a huge bonus
for the galaxy is the USB C port which
we still don't get on the iPhone and of
course you get the S Pen with the no
allowing for easy sketching note-taking
and document signing as far as the
displays it seems like Samsung is
supplying a very similar display for
both the note 10 plus and the iPhone 11
Pro with the same 1200 nits of peak
brightness the same two million to one
contrast and the same color accuracy
however the notes and plus has a higher
1440p resolution and it features an
always-on display which is a huge bonus
over the iPhone so it definitely has the
more pro display the note 10 plus also
has a larger battery 4300 milliamp hours
compared to 3500 on the 11pro Macs
so it seems like it should have better
battery life mister who's the boss ran a
battery life test and when the iPhone
tennis max died the note 10 plus was at
19 percent battery life however the note
was only at 1080p resolution instead of
1440p on top of that the always-on
display would use up some battery life
in the real world and since Apple showed
off a massive battery life improvement
with the iPhone 11 pro max there's a
very good chance that it could beat out
the note 10 plus in terms of battery
life even with a smaller battery all of
that comes thanks to some pretty
substantial energy efficiency
improvements on the 11 pro's new 813
Bionic chip the 812 Bionic from last
year's iPhone 10 s is already faster
than the snapdragon 855 in the note 10
plus this year the a 13 ship is taking
it a step further with even more
performance an updated knurl engine and
two new machine learning accelerators
that free up more of the processor to do
other tasks will definitely be comparing
performance when we get our hands on
them so make sure you're subscribed in
terms of speaker quality the note 10
plus absolutely destroyed the iPhone
10's max the only downside was a quieter
earpiece speaker because
had to slim it down greatly to reduce
the top bezel the 11pro should be
getting better speakers and now dolby
atmos support but there's a good chance
the note 10 plus the speakers might
still be better and finally let's finish
off with charging the note 10 plus does
feature reverse wireless charging which
is definitely an advantage for users who
own the Galaxy buds or want to revive a
friend's dead phone and the note 10 plus
also comes with a faster charger in the
Box 25 watts compared to 18 watts and
can charge to 100% twice as fast taking
about an hour compared to two not only
that but it supports up to a 45 watt
charger if you buy it separately so for
charging the note 10 plus definitely
beats the iPhone now let's answer the
final question which new smartphone is
more pro in our opinion the note 10 plus
is definitely the more pro smartphone
being a more feature-rich phone all
around and more worthy of the pro
branding you can tell that Samsung put
the best possible technology they could
into the note whereas Apple is clearly
holding features back for future
releases like an always-on display and
reverse wireless charging 64 gigabytes
base storage on the iPhone is way too
low for a pro device so it seems like
that decision was made to help sell more
iCloud subscriptions other than that it
seems like the iPhone 11 pro has a lot
of improvements under the hood that
we'll have to experience hands-on like
the cameras performance battery life and
more so definitely subscribe right now
by clicking the card above so you don't
miss out on our hands-on comparison
videos thanks for watching and we'll see
you in the next one
[Music]